[Musique]
j'aimerais que chacun votre tour où nous
dit est ce que vous êtes content ou pas
du retour de mathieu dit la vérité on
sait toujours tout dit ici pas dire mais
moi je suis contente évidemment qu'ils
reviennent parce qu' il a pu nous parler
et moi ce qui me manquait c'était ce
silence moi je voulais qu'ils pas
comprendre et je voulais juste qu'ils
nous disent
j'allais pas bien c'est pas contre vous
c'est pas contre l'émission je suis pas
là et voilà j'avais envie de juste de
dialoguer avec lui rokhaya fall qui ne
le connaissaient pas a priori oui
puisque contente de savoir que la raison
pour laquelle il revient c'est qu'il va
mieux quand même une bonne nouvelle
et voilà j'ai faim je suis très heureuse
de faire sa connaissance des sept
premières j'ai envie dans la vie aurait
beaucoup de potes on l'a peu d'amis
c'est mon avis dont évidemment je suis
ravi que c'est autour de la table ils
ont très bien joué
maxime qu'on vous aime ou pas vous
laisser personne indifférent si
longtemps vous soyez venu parce que vous
êtes un bon chroniqueur vous me faites
rire également valérie faire le show au
boulot la juste mesure parfois sur une
île il a l'air plus gentil mais j'espère
que vous avez progressé parce que
l'année dernière je vous mettais chaos à
chaque débat vous avez nous si on a
vraiment souffert je suis ravi que tu
reviennes tu le sais et cela dit la
première fois que tu me retraite de
vienne c'est vrai que depuis qu'il est
parti plus personne ne le fait
tu aille mieux et je suis très contente
que tu reviens ici merci moi et je les
dis il ya deux à trois jours c'est un
excellent élément dans l'émission il est
indispensable il est drôle bon
maintenant en coulisse j'espère que ça
ira mieux entre nous mais moi je suis
très content qu'il soit là mais ce qui
me fait rire évidemment très très très
souvent donc avoir à suivre
jean-luc on s'en fout de mon avis parce
que celle de l'espagne qui décideront de
et moi je vais être très honnête moins
mature et prêt à céder sur un moment
avec lui dans l'émission est très
brillant mais plein de fois l'aï revient
et c'est comme des retrouvailles après
une rupture qu'on n'a pas décidé en plus
donc il faut qu'on serait apprivoise
tout je pensais bien se passer donc y'a
pas de souci maintenant je veux pas dire
comme je l'attendais pas ce que je pense
vraiment que personne n'est
indispensable
à part vous une famille et même les
téléspectateurs
voilà la famille grandit chaque année
est vraiment je vous le dis on vous dit
où vous êtes notre famille on se
comporte à l'antenne comme on est dans
les coulisses et chaque personne pourra
dire le contraire et plein de choses qui
ont été dites sur cette émission
cette année l'ambiance est au top voilà
je voudrais les émissions sont au top on
est très très très content et mathieu
moi je voudrais juste te dire quelque
chose tu sais que je t'aime énormément
comme tous les chroniqueurs ici le
savent à tous femmes ont jamais je me
suis fâché à mort avec un chroniqueur et
tu sais que je t'aime très fort et je
suis très content que tu sois avec nous
demain pour ta première émission ici
[Applaudissements]